the European Parliament scientific
foresight unit or stola in collaboration
with the European Commission pad MEP s
and scientists for three days experiment
so they can keep ahead of the game in
research breakthroughs and avoid playing
catch-up have to educate our
parliamentarians within us the
developments in on a scientific level
and we now employ approximately 300
scientists within European Parliament
the climate for doing research in Europe
is great also it's very much stimulated
like the rotation of people with the
year twenty twenty on the horizon
european research needs a boost when it
comes to profitability are you up is
doing very well in terms of scientific
research is doing very well maybe we are
not as good as the u.s. in making money
out of it which is something that's been
for a long time so in my area all the
big companies are based in california
but a lot of the talent in those
companies comes from Europe you have to
breathe what politicians decide to do to
know exactly what the science is also
working on at the same time so that we
don't work against each other but
together any piece will then translate
this shared knowledge into a legal
framework with the aim to improve the
lives of the citizens they represent